Der variationelle Quanten-Eigenwert-Löser oder VQE ist einer der frühesten hybriden quantenklassischen Algorithmen und er ist
aus mehreren Gründen interessant. Erstens, wie wir in diesem Video sehen werden, ist er ein vielversprechender Ansatz für bestimmte Arten von Problemen. Zweitens ist er historisch
wichtig und hat den Weg für viele erweiterte Algorithmen wie adapt VQE geebnet.
Und schließlich ist VQE ziemlich einfach. Es ist leicht zu verstehen, was der Quanten- und der klassische Computer in diesem Algorithmus tun
und wie sie interagieren. Es gibt vier Hauptkomponenten einer VQE-Berechnung.
Erstens gibt es einen Operator, oft einen Hamiltonian, den wir H nennen, der eine Eigenschaft des Systems beschreibt, die
du optimieren möchtest. Anders ausgedrückt suchst du den Eigenvektor dieses Operators, der
dem minimalen Eigenwert entspricht. Wir nennen diesen Eigenvektor oft den Grundzustand.
Als nächstes gibt es einen Ansatz, was so viel wie Herangehensweise bedeutet. Dies ist ein Quanten-circuit, der einen Quantenzustand vorbereitet, der
den gesuchten Eigenvektor annähert. Eigentlich ist der Ansatz eine Familie von Quanten-circuits, weil einige der Gates im
Ansatz parametrisiert sind. Das heißt, sie erhalten einen Parameter, den wir variieren können. Diese Familie von Quanten-circuits
kann eine Familie von Quantenzuständen vorbereiten, die den Grundzustand annähern.
Als nächstes brauchen wir einen Estimator, ein Mittel zur Schätzung des Erwartungswerts des Operators H über den aktuellen variationellen
Quantenzustand. Manchmal interessiert uns einfach dieser Erwartungswert, den wir
als Kostenfunktion bezeichnen. Andere Male interessiert uns eine kompliziertere Funktion, die dennoch ausgehend von
einem oder mehreren Erwartungswerten geschrieben werden kann.
Schließlich brauchen wir einen klassischen Optimierer, einen Algorithmus, der Parameter variiert, um diese Kostenfunktion zu minimieren.
Lass uns das Problem skizzieren, das wir lösen wollen, und den allgemeinen Ansatz, bevor wir darauf eingehen, welche Rolle Quanten dabei spielen. Wir
können viele Optimierungsprobleme, die für Wissenschaft und Industrie entscheidend sind, als Matrixwertprobleme formulieren. Häufig willst du
den minimalen Eigenwert deiner Matrix und den entsprechenden Eigenvektor. Die Matrix H könnte ein
Hamiltonian sein, der die Energie eines physikalischen Systems beschreibt. Und der minimale Eigenwert wäre die Grundzustandsenergie
E0 und der Eigenvektor wäre der entsprechende Quanten-Grundzustand, oft als Psi sub0 bezeichnet.
Oder die Matrix könnte eine komplizierte Kostenfunktion beschreiben, die mit kombinatorischen Optimierungsproblemen verbunden ist,
wie zum Beispiel in der Logistik, und der Eigenzustand s subopt wäre eine optimale Lösung
des Problems, wie ein Binärstring, der einen Schnitt in einem Graphen eines Verteilungsnetzes kennzeichnet. In der Praxis ist es
üblich, den Begriff Hamiltonian für alle interessierenden Matrizen zu verwenden, auch außerhalb der Naturwissenschaften. Nehmen wir an,
wir interessieren uns für eine Matrix mit n Zeilen und n Spalten. Solche Probleme können schnell und exakt mit
klassischen Lösern gelöst werden für n bis zu einigen Hundert oder Tausend ohne Annahmen über die Matrix. Für dünnbesetzte
Matrizen, also solche mit hauptsächlich Nullen als Einträge, kann dies viel größer sein, mit n bis zu einer Milliarde, sogar auf einem Laptop.
Aber für wirklich riesige Probleme, die diese Zahlen übersteigen, sind oft approximative oder heuristische Methoden erforderlich.
Je größer die Matrix und je weniger dünnbesetzt, desto schwieriger das Problem und desto cleverere Tricks müssen angewandt werden. Angenommen, deine Matrix ist so
groß, dass exakte Diagonalisierung keine Option ist. Angenommen weiter, du weißt genug über dein Problem, dass du
einige Vermutungen über die Gesamtstruktur des Zielzustands anstellen kannst, und du möchtest Zustände erkunden, die deiner
anfänglichen Vermutung ähnlich sind, um zu sehen, ob deine Kosten oder Energie weiter gesenkt werden können. Das ist ein variationeller Ansatz und es ist eine Methode,
die verwendet wird, wenn exakte Diagonalisierung auf einem klassischen Computer keine Option ist. Das funktioniert wie folgt.
Zuerst machst du einen Versuchszustand mit einigen Parametern theta, die du variieren wirst.
Obwohl diese anfängliche Vermutung zufällig sein könnte, ist das nicht ratsam. Wir wollen das Wissen über das vorliegende Problem nutzen,
um unsere Vermutung so gut wie möglich anzupassen.
Zweitens würden wir den Erwartungswert des Operators berechnen, wenn sich das System in diesem Zustand befindet.
Drittens würden wir die variationellen Parameter ändern und wiederholen.
Viertens würden wir die gesammelten Informationen über die Landschaft möglicher Zustände in deinem variationellen Unterraum nutzen, um immer bessere
Vermutungen zu machen und uns dem Zielzustand zu nähern.
Das Variationsprinzip garantiert, dass unser variationeller Zustand keinen Eigenwert liefern kann, der niedriger ist als der des
Ziel-Grundzustands. Je niedriger also der Erwartungswert, desto besser unsere Annäherung an den Grundzustand. Lass uns
über die Schwierigkeit jedes Schritts in diesem Ansatz sprechen.
Das Setzen oder Aktualisieren von Parametern ist rechnerisch einfach. Die Schwierigkeit liegt in der Auswahl nützlicher, physikalisch
motivierter Anfangsparameter. Die Nutzung gesammelter Informationen aus früheren Iterationen zur Aktualisierung der Parameter, sodass
man sich dem Grundzustand nähert, ist nicht trivial. Aber es gibt klassische Optimierungsalgorithmen, die dies
ziemlich effizient tun. Diese klassische Optimierung ist nur deshalb aufwendig, weil sie möglicherweise viele
Iterationen erfordert. Im schlimmsten Fall kann die Anzahl der Iterationen exponentiell mit n skalieren.
Der rechnerisch aufwendigste Einzelschritt ist mit ziemlicher Sicherheit der Erwartungswert deiner Matrix mit einem
gegebenen Zustand. Die n-mal-n-Matrix muss auf den n-Element-Vektor angewandt werden, was im schlimmsten Fall der Ordnung n²
Multiplikationsoperationen entspricht. Das muss bei jeder Iteration der Parameter gemacht werden. Für extrem
große Matrizen hat das hohe Rechenkosten. Stell dir nun vor, diesen Teil der
Berechnung an einen Quantencomputer zu delegieren. Anstatt diesen Erwartungswert zu berechnen, schätzt du ihn, indem du den
Zustand s von theta auf dem Quantencomputer mit deinem variationellen Ansatz vorbereitest und dann Messungen durchführst.
Lass uns das etwas genauer betrachten. H ist generell nicht einfach zu messen. Zum Beispiel könnte er aus vielen
nicht-kommutierenden Pauli-X-, Y- und Z-Operatoren bestehen.
Aber H kann als Linearkombination von Termen H subalpha geschrieben werden, von denen jeder leicht messbar ist. Zum Beispiel
Pauli-Operatoren oder Gruppen von bitweise kommutierenden Pauli-Operatoren. Der
Erwartungswert von H über den Zustand S ist die gewichtete Summe der Erwartungswerte der einzelnen Terme H alpha.
Dieser Ausdruck gilt für jeden Zustand s, aber wir werden ihn speziell mit unserem variationellen Zustand s von theta verwenden.
Jeder der Terme h alpha kann m mal gemessen werden, wobei Messproben s subalpha j mit j von
1 bis m entstehen und einen Erwartungswert und eine Standardabweichung liefern. Wir können
diese Terme summieren und Fehler durch die Summe propagieren.
Das erfordert keine großangelegte Multiplikation und keinen Prozess, der notwendigerweise wie n² skaliert. Stattdessen
erfordert es mehrere Messungen auf dem Quantencomputer. Wenn du nicht zu viele davon brauchst, könnte dieser Ansatz
effizient sein. Und das ist der Quanten-Teil von VQE. Aber lass uns über Gründe sprechen, warum das möglicherweise nicht effizient ist. Ein Grund
für viele Messungen ist die Reduzierung der statistischen Unsicherheit in deinen Schätzungen für sehr hochpräzise
Berechnungen. Ein weiterer Grund ist die Anzahl der Pauli-Strings, die erforderlich sind, um deine gesamte Matrix aufzuspannen. Da Pauli-Matrizen plus die
Identität den Raum aller Operatoren einer gegebenen Dimension aufspannen, ist garantiert,
dass wir unsere interessierende Matrix als gewichtete Summe von Pauli-Operatoren schreiben können, wie wir es zuvor getan haben. Hier ist C alpha ein
numerischer Koeffizient und H alpha ist ein String von Pauli-Operatoren, die auf alle Qubits wirken, die dein System beschreiben.
H alpha hätte eine Form wie diese, wobei der n-te Pauli-Operator von rechts auf das n-te Qubit wirkt. Also können wir
unseren Operator messen, indem wir eine Reihe von Pauli-Operatoren messen. Aber wir können nicht alle diese Pauli-Operatoren
gleichzeitig messen. Pauli-Operatoren ohne die Identität kommutieren nicht miteinander, wenn sie
mit demselben Qubit verknüpft sind. Zum Beispiel können wir I Z IIZ und ZZ
XZ gleichzeitig messen, weil wir I und Z gleichzeitig für das dritte
Qubit messen können. Und wir können I und X gleichzeitig für das erste Qubit messen. Aber wir können nicht
alle Z's und ZZ ZX gleichzeitig messen, weil Z und X nicht
kommutieren und beide auf das nullte Qubit wirken.
Also zerlegen wir unsere Matrix H in eine Summe von Paulis, die auf verschiedene Qubits wirken.
Einige Elemente dieser Summe können alle auf einmal gemessen werden. Wir nennen das eine Gruppe kommutierender Paulis. Je nachdem,
wie viele nicht-kommutierende Terme es gibt, brauchen wir möglicherweise viele solcher Gruppen. Nennen wir die Anzahl solcher Gruppen kommutierender
Paulis t.
Wenn ngcp klein ist, könnte das gut funktionieren.
Wenn h Millionen von Gruppen hat, wird das nicht nützlich sein. Du zeichnest den Erwartungswert oder die Kostenfunktion
für die Menge der Parameter theta auf, die in deinem Zustand verwendet werden, und dann aktualisierst du die Parameter über die Zeit. Du könntest die
Erwartungswerte oder Kostenfunktionswerte, die du geschätzt hast, verwenden, um einen Gradienten deiner Kostenfunktion im
Unterraum der von deinem Ansatz abgetasteten Zustände zu approximieren.
Sowohl gradientenbasierte als auch gradientenfreie klassische Optimierer existieren. Beide leiden unter potenziellen Trainierbarkeits-Problemen wie
mehreren lokalen Minima und großen Regionen des Parameterraums mit nahezu null Gradienten, sogenannten Barren Plateaus.
Wird VQE also all deine schwierigsten Probleme lösen? Nein. Aber bei allen Berechnungen besser zu sein, war nie der Punkt. Wir haben
verschoben, was die Rechenkosten bestimmt. Schau dir an, was wir getauscht haben. Wir sind von einem Prozess gewechselt,
dessen Komplexität nur von der Matrixdimension abhängt, zu einem, der von der erforderlichen Präzision und der Anzahl der
nicht-kommutierenden Pauli-Operatoren abhängt, aus denen die Matrix besteht. Der letzte Punkt hat kein Analogon im klassischen Computing.
Basierend auf diesen neuen Abhängigkeiten kann dieser Prozess für dünnbesetzte Matrizen oder Matrizen mit wenigen nicht-kommutierenden Pauli-Strings
nützlich sein. Das ist der Fall für Systeme wechselwirkender Spins. Zum Beispiel kann es für dichte Matrizen
weniger nützlich sein. Wir wissen zum Beispiel, dass chemische Systeme oft Hamiltonians haben, die Hunderte, Tausende, sogar
Millionen von Pauli-Strings umfassen. Es gab interessante Arbeiten, um diese Anzahl von Termen zu reduzieren, aber
chemische Systeme sind möglicherweise besser für einige der anderen Algorithmen geeignet, die wir in diesem Kurs besprechen werden.
Die effektive Nutzung von VQE erfordert auch, dass wir Eigenschaften unseres Zielzustands kennen und einen guten, physikalisch
motivierten Anfangszustand sowie einen guten Ansatz mit relativ wenigen variationellen Parametern auswählen können. Das kann
ziemlich herausfordernd sein. VQE zeigt, wie die Stärken klassischer und Quantencomputer kombiniert werden können,
ohne neuere Methoden hinzuzufügen. VQE hilft uns nicht, Probleme zu lösen, die für klassische Computer unlösbar sind, aber
es spielt weiterhin eine Rolle in der Algorithmenentwicklung. Und VQE lehrt uns auch, dass das Übertragen eines Schritts vom klassischen
auf den Quantencomputer weder für alle Zwecke besser noch schlechter ist. Vielmehr
ändert es, welche Faktoren die Effizienz deines Algorithmus bestimmen. Das ist eine wichtige allgemeine Lektion im quanten-
klassischen hybriden Computing.